einigung im flüchtlingsstreit union und
spd wollen weitere rund 1500 migranten
aus griechenland aufnehmen
mehr geld für impfstoff entwicklungen
die bundesregierung fördert drei
deutsche pharmafirmen und geht von einem
corona sehr um im kommenden jahr aus
mission asteroiden abwehr die
europäische raumfahrtbehörde erforscht
wie gefährliche gesteinsbrocken im all
umgelenkt werden können
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem dienstag norbert lehmann ist auch
dabei für den sport allgemein under von
mir
wir beginnen mit der griechischen insel
lesbos für tausende flüchtlinge dort
bricht gleich die achte nacht auf dem
asphalt an die bundesregierung will
helfen wie und in welchem umfang darüber
gingen die meinungen auseinander
nun sind sich union und spd einig
zusätzlich zu den schon beschlossenen
150 minderjährigen die ohne begleitung
in griechenland sind dürfen weitere 1553
geflüchtete nach deutschland kommen
alles familien von den griechischen
inseln david gebhard berichtet noch
immer campieren menschen im freien auf
der insel lesbos nun sollen geflüchtete
aus griechenland in deutschland
zusätzlich aufgenommen werden
darauf haben sich die koalitionspartner
am nachmittag überraschend verständigt
es sind etwa 1500 personen in familien
mit kindern die jetzt von allen inseln
in griechenland geholt werden und damit
wird entlastung überall möglich sein
die situation in moria wird dadurch auch
entlastung erfahren ein eigenständiger
deutscher beitrag soll es sein darauf
hatten sich zuvor auch bundeskanzlerin
und innenminister verständigt zusätzlich
wird eine europäische lösung angestrebt
doch die hakt seit jahren
ich hätte mir gewünscht dass wir das im
rahmen einer gesamteuropäischen lösung
machen das ist nicht gelungen
und wenn wir es nicht schaffen die
migrationspolitik zu europäisieren
dann werden wir auch in zukunft vor
ähnlichen problemen stehen wie vor dem
problem vor denen wir jetzt stehen
wem soll in deutschland geholfen werden
insbesondere aus dem abgebrannten
flüchtlingslager moria aus der
opposition in berlin heute gänzlich
unterschiedliche forderungen ich helfen
würde wäre eine klare ansage der eu
ratspräsidentschaft das ist deutschland
wie evakuieren diese menschen alle die
werden nicht alle nach deutschland
kommen es gibt ja auch in europa noch
andere länder andere kommunen regionen
die bereits in menschen aufzunehmen das
würde ich nicht so wirkung erzeugen und
einen anreiz auch erzeugen nach
deutschland
und das kann nicht im sinn unser aller
seien eigentlich die bundesregierung
entscheidet sich zusätzlich zu helfen
das soll eine humanitäre geste sein die
den einst so weit geht und anderen
längst nicht weit genug
wir holen unsere korrespondenten aus
berlin und lesbos dazu zunächst theo
koll wer hat sich jetzt in diesem streit
durchgesetzt
also gewonnen haben auf jeden fall die
1553 menschen denen jetzt in deutschland
schutz gewährt hat politisch ist das
ganze ein kompromiss bei dem beide
seiten für sich in anspruch nehmen
werden sich durchgesetzt zu haben
die spd hat erreicht dass dieses
kontingent das zehnfache der von
seehofer in einem ersten schritt der
zugesagten bis zu 150 jugendlichen ist
andererseits ist es aber deutlich
weniger als die spd-vorsitzende esken
bei uns im zdf gefordert hatte dort
sprach sie von einer hohen vierstelligen
zahl das hat sie ganz offensichtlich
nicht durchsetzen können denn die zahl
1500 war schon heute morgen von merkel
und seehofer festgelegt worden aber es
wird ja eine wie auch immer geartete
weitere europäische aufnahme geben und
auf den deutschen anteil daran werden
die jetzigen zusagen nicht angerechnet
das dürfte dann den kompromiss etwas
ausgeglichener machen
andreas postel auf lesbos kann sich
überhaupt jemand von den flüchtlingen
aus moriya hoffnungen machen jetzt nach
deutschland zu kommen sicherlich weit
weniger als sicher hoffen die
griechische regierung hier verfolgt
andere interessen in erster linie
versuchen die behörden seit tagen die
menschen hier in dem provisorischen
zeltlager hinter mir unterzubringen und
corona tests zu machen und zu einem
geordneten asylverfahren zurückzukommen
und das zweite was griechenlands
premierminister hier immer wieder betont
ist man werde sich nicht erpressen
lassen von brandstiftern erzwingen
wollen aufs festland gebracht zu werden
denn was außer acht gelassen wird auch
auf den anderen osteuropäischen inseln
sind migranten untergebracht und der zum
teil ähnlich schweren verhältnissen wie
zuletzt auf moorea es geht also jetzt
hier um die 408 familien deren
asylstatus geklärt ist und die eben
nicht nur von lesbos kommen dankeschön
nach lesbos und berlin
zur pandemie bislang hat die welt dem
corona virus nicht viel entgegenzusetzen
außer masken und abstands und
hygieneregeln die große hoffnung ist ein
impfstoff in deutschland so die
zuständigen minister heute könnte mitte
kommenden jahres einer für alle bereit
stehen allerdings sind noch viele fragen
offen
dazu gleich mehr zunächst nina
niebergall über den stand der
entwicklung
bevor ein impfstoff zugelassen wird muss
er getestet werden und zwar für
gewöhnlich in drei phasen in phase 1
wird er weniger als 100 freiwilligen
verabreicht gesunden menschen um die
verträglichkeit zu testen
in phase zwei dann mehreren hundert
menschen darunter auch corona erkrankten
um zu sehen wie das immunsystem reagiert
entscheidend phase 3
tausende bekommen den möglichen
impfstoff damit wird sichergestellt dass
keine massiven nebenwirkungen auftreten
und dass er tatsächlich wirkt acht
impfstoffentwickler sind schon in dieser
dritten phase darunter das russische
gamma lea institute deren impfstoff
sputnik wie wurde schon vor ende der
tests im august zugelassen und das
deutsche unternehmen bei montech es
hofft auf eine baldige zulassung wenn
möglich schon im oktober
die bundesregierung will die entwicklung
weiter beschleunigen und fördert
biontech und zwei weitere deutsche
pharmaunternehmen mit insgesamt 750
millionen euro
dabei gehe es nicht darum erster zu sein
betont gesundheitsminister sparen
sondern darum einen sicheren und
wirksamen wirkstoff zu finden
christoph des tarim mit details ein
ganzer planet ist verunsichert und fragt
sich wann kommt die waffe gegen korona
ab wann kann geimpft werden heute aus
berlin ein vorsichtiges versprechen 2021
aber und das gehört auch zur wahrheit
dazu nach wie vor müssen wir uns darauf
einstellen dass es erst mitte nächsten
jahres einen impfstoff gibt mit dem
breite teile der bevölkerung geimpft
werden können und zur wahrheit gehört
noch lässt sich überhaupt nicht sagen
was die impfstoffe dann genau können
werden vielleicht ansteckungen
verhindern vielleicht nur schwere
krankheitsverläufe prinzip hoffnung also
auch für die labore
vom ersten bis zum letzten test da ist
es dabei am ende auch immer das problem
dass man ganz am ende dieser phasen auch
es sagen kann ob dieser im stoff
wirklich sicher ist und ob dieser
impfstoff auch effektives bei drei
deutschen firmen hat berlin das gefühl
die mit geld zu fördern lohnt sich auch
bei montech in mainz genießt diesen
vertrauensvorschuss und will und muss
schon jetzt vollgas geben
wir möchten zusammen mit unserem partner
phase in 2020 bis zu 100 millionen dosen
impfstoff bereit stellen und für 20
jahren 20 haben uns vorgenommen bis zu
1,3 milliarden impfstoff herzustellen
und derweil diskutieren ethiker werden
zuerst geimpft werden soll wenn es
soweit ist wohl mediziner und
pflegepersonal dann ältere menschen und
risikopatienten wobei klare ansage aus
berlin jeder und jede für sich die wahl
haben es wird zu einer freiwilligen
impfung kommen
wir sind sehr sehr zuversichtlich dass
wir das ziel einer ausreichend hohen
impfquote freiwillig erreichen mit einer
hohen akzeptanz für impfung bis dahin
noch mal so einen großen locker und wie
im märz sieht der gesundheitsminister
übrigens nicht dafür hätten wir
inzwischen alle zu viel gelernt über das
virus und wie man es in schach hält
die korona zahlen sehen im moment so aus
im schnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich hierzulande täglich 1.370
menschen neu angesteckt gestern waren es
1430 der kritische wert von 50
neuinfektionen pro 100.000 einwohnern
wird derzeit in würzburg kaufbeuren und
dem kreis garmisch-partenkirchen
überschritten nach washington zu einer
besonderen zeremonie im weißen haus zu
gast beim us-präsidenten besonderer
besuch aus dem nahen osten ein treffen
das es so noch nie gegeben hat
deswegen spricht schon von einem
historischen durchbruch neue allianzen
entstehen denn israel will nach ägypten
und jordanien jetzt auch mit den
vereinigten arabischen emiraten und
bahrain diplomatische beziehungen
aufnehmen
aus washington berichtet ines trams
historische zusammenkunft im weißen haus
die außenminister bach 1 und der
vereinigten arabischen emirate dazu
israels ministerpräsident netanjahu
nach über einem vierteljahrhundert will
israel mit zwei weiteren arabischen
staaten diplomatische beziehungen
aufnehmen
sieben wochen vor der wahl us-präsident
trump gibt sich als friedensstifter
wir haben die vielen nationen die
ebenfalls folgen wollen ich kann jetzt
nicht sagen welche aber es wird so
kommen
dies sind sehr starke übereinkommen dies
ist frieden ernsthafter frieden israel
genießt den größten diplomatischen
triumph seiner geschichte die tyrannen
im iran sind isoliert bei präsident fand
solchen druck ausgeübt hat lange schon
gab es kontakte der beiden länder zu
israel nun will man es offiziell machen
botschaften austauschen und die
beziehungen ausbauen
in wirtschaft handel und flugverkehr der
gemeinsame feind iran 1 sie sagen sich
loos vom versprechen keine annäherung an
israel vor lösung der palästinenserfrage
die protestieren auch vor dem weißen
haus trump bezog sie kaum mit 1 eine
zwei staaten lösung nicht in sicht
schramms motivation diese verträge voran
zu treiben ist in der region
eine koalition gegen iran zu schmieden
und er will innenpolitisch punkten vor
allem bei den christlichen evangelikalen
die israel nahe stehen ein wirklich
nachhaltiger frieden ist nicht sein
vorrangiges ziel im garten des weißen
hauses sollen in wenigen minuten die
verträge unterzeichnet werden historisch
doch frieden ist in der region damit
nicht garantiert
israel hofft auf neue partner und
wirtschaftliche chancen michael weber in
tel aviv aber die palästinenser bleiben
außen vor
welche konsequenzen hat das also moment
scheint sich die palästinensische
führung noch immer im schockzustand zu
befinden und noch immer nicht ganz
wahrhaben zu wollen was da gerade
passiert und was da passiert ist nicht
weniger dass der wichtigste eckstein der
bisherigen strategie weggebrochen ist
nämlich die zusage der arabischen
staaten ihre außenpolitik zwingend an
die lösung der palästina-frage zu binden
das zeigt nicht nur der abschluss des
vertrages heute sondern auch eine
sitzung der arabischen liga letzte woche
wo sich die liga weigerte einen antrag
der palästinenser zu unterstützen in dem
dieser vertrag heute in bausch und bogen
abgelehnt wird
die palästinensischen politik steht nun
am scheideweg und muss sich überlegen
wie es weitergeht moment sieht es so aus
als wolle man stärker mit der radikalen
hamas kooperieren allein schon um mehr
einigkeit des palästinensischen volkes
nach außen zu demonstrieren
michael bewerunge live aus tel aviv
danke für diese einschätzung und über
das abkommen haben wir auch mit dem
nahost experte michael lüders gesprochen
das interview und weitere
hintergrundinformationen finden sie in
der zdf- heute- app und auf heute.de
noch mal zurück in die usa um sich vor
ort ein bild von den verheerenden
waldbränden zu machen hat präsident jump
ein betroffenes gebiet in kalifornien
besucht dort leugnete er erneut den
klimawandel
es wird wieder kühler werden sie werden
schon sehen so tappen sein
demokratischer herausforderer beiden
kritisierte ihn dafür scharf
der daimler konzern zahlt in den usa
umgerechnet 1,9 milliarden euro so soll
der diesel abgas streit mit behörden und
kunden beigelegt werden
die zivilrechtlichen
ermittlungsverfahren und eine
sammelklage seien damit vom tisch heißt
es vom us justizministerium und vom
stuttgarter autobauer
ein gericht muss dem noch zustimmen
daimler wurden überhöhte abgaswerte bei
rund 250.000 autos vorgeworfen
die autoindustrie leidet unter
absatzkrise und corona pandemie und
streicht weiter stellen und standorte
continental will eines seiner beiden
großen reifenwerke in deutschland nicht
machen
die produktion in aachen soll bis ende
kommenden jahres geschlossen werden
betroffen wären 1800 mitarbeiter die
pläne sind teil des sparkurses beim
zweit größten autozulieferer der welt
wir dürfen niemals schweigen sagt
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
und zeigt sich besorgt über hass und
hetze gegen juden in deutschland an
einem tag der eigentlich ein jubiläum
feiert der zentralrat der juden in
deutschland wird 70 jahre alt er
vertritt 105 jüdische gemeinden und
verleiht so und 100.000 gläubigen eine
stimme stephan merseburger berichtet 70
jahre zentralrat der juden in
deutschland zur berechtigten freude
darüber mischt sich sorge angesichts
antisemitischer hetze und gewalt neben
den schlimmen antisemitischen vorfällen
sind es die kleinen ausgrenzungen die
viele juden regelmäßig erleben die uns
sorge machen
leise stellt sich die frage wie sicher
mir noch in diesem land leben können
die israel feindlichkeit nimmt zu der
antisemitismus von muslimen und
rechtsextremen wächst terror in halle
und jede menge hass im netz
es ist eine schande und beschämt mich
zutiefst sie sich rassismus und
antisemitismus in unserem land in diesen
zeiten äußern
nach nazi terror und industrielle
massenmorde in konzentrationslagern
leben 1945 noch 15.000 juden in
deutschland
1950 wird der zentralrat der juden
gegründet
er hilft bei der ausreise nach israel
und kämpft für die wiedergutmachung des
ns unrechts zaghaft der neubeginn in der
bundesrepublik werden vereinzelt
synagogen gebaut
nach dem fall des eisernen vorhangs
wächst die jüdische gemeinde rasant von
20.000 auf etwa 100.000 juden aus
ehemaligen sowjetstaaten ziehen nach
deutschland
neben ihre religion besuch am
kreuzberger fraenkelufer in einer
schnell wachsenden jüdischen gemeinde
manche sind in berlin geboren viele
eingewandert sowie us empire aus israel
es gibt antisemitismus aber ich muss
mich drauf einlassen
in dem moment wo ich als jude die
entscheidung getroffen habt hier in
berlin in deutschland zu leben
deutschland ist ihre heimat sie wollen
sie selbstbewusst mitgestalten
vor knapp vier wochen wurde der
kremlkritiker alexej nawalny mit dem
kampfstoff novikov vergiftet er kam ins
künstliche koma heute hat sich der 44
jährige erstmals gemeldet in berlin vom
krankenbett aus
ein auf instagram veröffentlichtes foto
zeigt ihn mit seinen kindern und seiner
frau schriftlich heißt es dazu an seine
freunde
hallo hier navalny ich habe euch
vermisst und ich kann noch immer fast
nichts machen aber ich habe gestern den
ganzen tag selbstständig geatmet
wir gehen ins alle meteoriten das sind
brocken von asteroiden oder kometen die
in der erdatmosphäre nicht komplett
verglühen
manche sind nur faustgroß andere können
große trat er in die erdoberfläche
schlagen eine ernsthafte gefahr für die
menschheit sind sie nicht anders dagegen
so ein ganzer asteroid er kann 100
kilometer groß sein um zu verhindern
dass so ein brocken mit der erde
kollidiert haben sich jetzt die
weltraumbehörde esa und nasa
zusammengetan hinten klinge berichtet
wie aus dem nichts kam 2013 der asteroid
der ist in teilen bis zur erde schaffte
und eine kleine stadt in russland
verwüstete
die esa und die nasa planen jetzt
gemeinsam eine mission zur abwehr von
asteroiden
im nächsten jahr wollen zunächst die
amerikaner eine sonde ins all schicken
ihr ziel der doppel- asteroid didi muss
den kleineren soll der satellit rammen
und aus der bahn werfen
erst dann wird die esa ihre raumsonde
hera hinterher senden die wird
hinfliegen die wird zunächst den krater
vermessen wird die struktur und das
material dieses asteroiden analysieren
wir werden den grad der auslenkung
analysieren und dann rückschlüsse ziehen
wie eine solche mission im ernstfall zu
konzipieren ist bauen wird die
europäische sonde federführend eine
deutsche firma heute die unterzeichnung
des 129 millionen euro vertrags bei der
esa an diesem sehr sehr kleinen
asteroiden ist natürlich sehr
kompliziert und muss auch autonom
stattfinden da kann man mich woanders
von der erde warten weil das viel zu
lange dauern würde
diese technik ist einmalig es ist eine
historische mission denn noch nie zuvor
wurde versucht asteroiden von der erde
weg zu lenken und so als gefahr
auszuschalten
jetzt tour de france norbert mit dem
ersten deutschen etappe nach zwei jahren
ganz starke leistung von lennart kemner
der ja zu den jüngsten fahrern dieser
tour gehört der 24 jährige gewann die
erste alpenetappe mit großem vorsprung
feierte seinen bislang grössten
karriere-erfolg
es ist die zeit für große gefühle hier
in lahde long am ort seines größten
erfolges des größten erfolges von
lennart kemmler
ja alles sagen ich ziemlich ziemlich
cool einfach ein schöner moment
schon beim start ist klar heute wird ein
tag für ausreißer schnell bildet sich
auch eine entsprechende spitzengruppe
mit lennart kenner das hauptfeld schon
bald mehr als 10 minuten zurück vorn ist
die spitzengruppe derweil auf zwei
geschrumpft immer noch mit lennart
kenner der 20 kilometer vor dem ziel
entscheidend antritt und sich vom
letzten begleiter carabas löst kenner
baut seinen vorsprung immer weiter aus
seinen etappensieg am ende ungefährdet
so gibt es genug zeit für große gefühle
am ort seines größten erfolges ganz groß
die zeit der geisterspiele in der
fußball-bundesliga und anderen profi
ligen ist vorbei
die bundesländer einigten sich heute auf
eine sechswöchige testphase mit stark
reduzierter zuschauerkapazität es ist
ein beschluss mit signalwirkung nicht
nur für den fußball aber die vorsicht
bleibt gross wohl auch wegen dieser
bilder ohne großem abstand aus der
ersten pokalrunde nur 20 prozent der
plätze dürfen zunächst besetzt werden
das soll ein erster schritt zurück zu
vollen stadion und hallen sein denn
darauf sind viele sportarten angewiesen
wir hätten uns ein klein wenig mehr
versprochen aber das ist in ordnung ich
glaube wenn wir jetzt erstmal loslegen
dann ist der geist aus der flasche
draußen auf dauer erreichen sind 20%
natürlich nicht aus ich kann ihnen sagen
die handball bundesliga rechnet sonst in
der saison im durchschnitt 85 bis 90
prozent auslastung bis dahin ist es noch
ein weiter weg jetzt sind die zuschauer
gefragt das in sie gesetzte vertrauen
auch zu rechtfertigen
bvb spieler marco reus hat das
schnellste tor eines einwechselspielers
in der pokalgeschichte erzielt gestern
abend traf er in duisburg in der 58
minute genau drei sekunden nach
spielfortsetzung zum 50
und das nach 222 tagen ohne
pflichtspiele
toll das wetter bringt morgen neben
sonne auch mal einzelne gewitter zu den
aussichten gleich gunther tiersch das
heute-journal wie gewohnt um viertel vor
zehn mit marietta slomka
danke für ihr interesse machen sie sich
noch einen schönen abend und bis morgen
wenn sie mögen
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
mai nahmen die zuschauer mit bis zu 34
grad sind heute temperaturrekorde
gefallen noch nie war es im september so
heiß bei uns und es geht auch heiß und
überwiegend sonnig morgen weiter dieses
hochdruckgebiet was über osteuropa liegt
schwächelte zwar und die luft wird auch
etwas feuchter so bekommen wir ein paar
schauer und gewitter in den
nachmittagsstunden zum anderen aber
erreicht uns jetzt kühlere luft aber
zunächst nur die küste am donnerstag
dann ganz deutschland heute nacht
sternenklarer himmel ein paar
nebelfelder
und es würde erfrischend kühl für die
meisten 11 bis 15 grad nur am rhein
entlang oder auch in sachsen 18 bis 20
grad deutlich milder und morgen wird für
die meisten von uns heiß wieder also 25
bis 32 grad verbreitet die temperaturen
nur an den küsten ist es schon etwas
frischer geworden
20 22 grad da haben wir schon den
nordwind der an der nordsee kräftig weht
am vormittag scheint noch überall die
sonne und zum nachmittag hin dann kam
mir die quellwolken im süden entstehen
schauer und gewitter später wird auch an
der nordsee bewölkt aber es bleibt dort
wohl trocken
die aussichten donnerstag schon etwas
kühler bei uns dazu noch einige gewitter
im süden freitag/samstag sonniges wetter
und noch etwa 17 bis 27 grad
ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen abend
und machen sie's gut